[Applause]
now mark is going to explain to us what
is a pokemane okay and what is it
you're on the cutting edge of culture
yeah and you always claim that and you
taught us all what p is and he taught us
a lot of different things about the
internet okay so there's pokemon and
pokemane
are the cards that logan bought for
three and a half million yeah
yes that's exactly what pokemane is okay
so basically there's all this twitch
drama yes and you already know about
this yeah twitch yeah twitch is a app
yeah so where you could talk on it yeah
and so everybody talks and twitches on
it yeah so yeah so you be for the
[ __ ] on the island okay she make it
clap she make a clap
21 gets feel like i'm savage all right
so pogo is so confused dog he had no
idea i don't know about tortillas
you don't know about tory lanez bad
[ __ ] she might get clap clap crap
come on
yeah toes
yeah but what does that have to do with
twitch that was done on twitch bro you
didn't know that yo yo al you're [ __ ]
washed
no you're gen z bro you're a degenerate
i'm a degenerate z you still don't know
pokey mate you know what i mean i'm just
gen z bro don't [ __ ] with me i know
pokeman that's gucci mane's cousin
okay pokeyman liberal talk what is
pokemon so basically pokeman's a
streamer it's hawaiian gucci yeah
okay uh and then there's ninja
i know ninja i know ninja who's ninja
ninja yeah
is a uh streamer that's that's true and
he would play video games he got crazy
hair and he was like the first guy to go
mainstream and be popular yeah he's 1800
he's big on twitch yeah he's big on
twitter and then he went to a bunch of
different uh platforms he got kind of
ellen energy a bit yeah yeah you do have
a little eleanor little ellen energy he
plays video games with drake yeah that's
right
quitting he like rage quits like
yeah that's some loser ass [ __ ] all
right go so then there's another
streamer called gideon yeah jimmy is lit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm actually
not positive if i'm pronouncing that
[ __ ] right because i don't know
his stream it's judeon yeah
yeah actually there's a capital d in
there yeah it's judea all right singers
basically here's what happened all right
so the streamer dion
went at pokemon and started hate
streaming on her uh on her stream he
like started like sending all these like
uh hateful messages and like hate
botting on her chat oh wow going crazy
yeah
you're using the wrong term but whatever
that's fine okay
that's fine
i'm trying to use the terms you guys
understand yeah use the ones we
understand we understand all the terms
bro don't rage quit on us yeah [ __ ]
dark i know loser
you just got to say dead don't say i'm
dead
just go dead you know what i'm saying
all right
so pokeyman was getting rated
hate rated go yeah whatever yeah and
what were they saying about her some
crazy [ __ ] can you say any of the words
legally no oh why is crazy twitch will
stream the bananas oh [ __ ] all right my
bad and that's what happened to jay dion
oh so jedeon got banned yes for talking
all that [ __ ] against pokeman and hate
raiders okay hate rage yeah
and ninja are boys oh so ninja so jedeon
goes on ninja stream and basically gets
a super chat and pops in there and goes
yo like can you help me get unbanned i
got unfairly banned i need you to reach
out to your people at twitch get me
unbanned and then ninja said andrew's
like all right yeah bet you're my boy
i'm not really gonna look into it i got
you yeah calls his representative he's
like yo i'm gonna text him right now he
said [ __ ] be wildin though uh maybe
did he say [ __ ] be wildly that [ __ ]
who ninja said this ninja said it my
ninja
real talk she says
bro and then uh and then now pokeman and
all her fans are like yo why is ninja
backing up this guy that was being a
piece of [ __ ]
like why why is ninja backing up gideon
after he was talking all that [ __ ] to
pokemon yeah so ninja can't back up his
boy what did pokemane do nothing
what does she do she streams doing what
she's talking about the world bro my my
understanding is she's playing a
character and that's why they're being
critical of her a little bit and that
the character is like
what is it called the girlfriend
character i mean that's all these like
the big female twist streamers right
even if they're gaming they're like yeah
in real life though she actually has a
boyfriend or a husband or some [ __ ] but
she doesn't talk about that and she's
pretending to be this character online
to like lure these like in-cell dudes
who think that they have some sort of
relationship with her so it's like only
fans but like life
yeah basically but it's mostly underage
people because they're on twitch
and she's not doing anything overtly
sexual but she is potentially
manipulating them emotionally to keep
them locked in some could say some
because some was that the criticism of
her i don't know what that's the actual
like if that they were actually hating
on her for digion says she gets [ __ ]
down
real talk yeah yo digion said that yeah
that's why he got it that's why he got
kicked out digimon is going at pokemon i
like digimon a lot but yeah i know
that's what i'm team did you and he
technically she getting [ __ ] down she
got a man yeah
yeah yeah so i say nothing all that [ __ ]
he's complimenting the guy actually he
gets banned ninja is now basically
backing up his boy yeah and then it
becomes a whole drama like the ninja's
manager who's also his wife is going
back and forth in the dms with pokeman
like he never said that he never said he
was going to back him up pokemon goes on
her stream she's like well here's proof
of him saying it receives he got
received he got receipts
ninja and all his team is like yo we're
going to sue pokemon for defamation whoa
whoa
lying on her stream
about him yeah and is that lawsuit
actually happening that's what that's
what his team says um
chelsea yeah this one's tough because i
like pokemane too she's what is it that
you like about her she's just cool
you know she's not trying to sell sex
and [ __ ] like that she's not she's not
one of those twitchers that like
have a bikini and a [ __ ] pool in the
living room and [ __ ] like that
yeah
and i think she's like
oh she kind of looks like an anime girl
that's why people like her
i
see
okay
okay so what's your take as a gen z
expert as a gen z expert he's not jen's
the expert he's a gen z er i'm a gen z
yo first of all stop hating on shorty
like you hate us
because you anus
if she wasn't popping she wasn't the
number one most streamed person or
whatever the [ __ ] she is i'm sure you
wouldn't be worried about her tactics
and how she gets people to listen up um
you're gonna hate her because she got
that spot and you try to come for that
spot you hate her cause she's greater
that's it
yeah is what she doing manipulative okay
maybe sure but what are you gonna say
people aren't allowed to play characters
on stream it's like every one of the
rappers that we like is playing a
character we seem to be okay with that
mm-hmm jealous right jealous and
jealousy
it might be some jealousy bro ninja had
his time in the sun
right and i'm not saying he's from the
land of the rising one but that's what
his name would imply but he's no longer
maybe there maybe he's a little jealous
too maybe he liked when he was in all
them commercials he liked gaming with
all them famous people now he's not
getting the same response he used to get
he's feeling a little salty everybody
talking about pokemane
so what would you do what would be your
advice to ninja if i'm pokemon i'm not
even talking about these [ __ ]
oh yeah it's like you're not even on my
radar what if you're ninja he just tried
to back up his boy and then all of a
sudden his boy did some foul [ __ ] now
he's got a back pedal i don't know it
could be also like i'm gonna back up my
boy because it's good to insert myself
in this drama
because now people are talking about now
you got us talking about it other people
talking about maybe he needs a little
bit of that algo boost you know and he
did it a little corny though why because
when dg main called him he said oh i'm
going to put in a word and try to help
you
it's all it don't matter yeah so
yeah yeah when digimon called him yeah
um he said i i'ma put in a word to my
rep yeah and then he claimed that he
never put in the words his rep so now
you lying to your friend
and you're trying to say
i don't like that move
that's [ __ ] up yo that is [ __ ] up yo
did you man been loyal to him ask for
one favor you're supposed to be homies
ninja can't even back him up
low-key i kind of want to have digiman's
back here bro oh i'm team digimon i'm
team digital but hate rating is whack
though why you hate why are you hating
yeah he's a black
streamer i got a sport i'll respect
that's fair i got a sport that's fair
i've got many of us in the game i
respect that you're one of them
yeah bro you're out here streaming too
twitch is cracking dawg oh really what's
your twitch
[Laughter]
we talked about a woman with two vaginas
yeah we need a miles cam that just looks
at how bored
holy [ __ ]
the guy isn't even faking it he's got
his phone in front of us like this with
his head [ __ ]
can i [ __ ] tell you how to discuss it
all those miles an hour ago go tell me
i'm talking about russell peters we're
all talking about him and then miles
goes yeah you better yeah miles goes
miles goes
who is that
i've never been more disgusted in my
life i swear to god i got up and walked
out the room alex was here i couldn't
believe he didn't know russell peters
bro come on who is that who is that
and then five minutes later he's like
oh i've seen this dude on a couple of
british television shows what the [ __ ]
brooke
come on
he was on graham norton wasn't he
not eight out of 10 cats eight out of 10
cats
yeah thank you thank you yeah
they also was on that yeah fair enough
okay just to wrap up this whole pokemon
digimon ninja conversation
um
i think digimon is the future okay yeah
really you think he's the future i think
he's the future but pokemon is done now
ninja's the best pokeman is the now i
think digiman is the future and i think
ninja is the past
i'm on board with that i really do
believe this is wrong because i don't
think you know really what's going on
yeah that's the only thing like did you
man
he's going like six nine strategy with
it it's like yo you got the talent did
you man yeah like you are gonna take
over right you got the gift you got the
juice yeah did you made on the bottom
i want digimon on the pot anything i
could do to push his streams like get
more people over to digi mian's area
we just got to calm him down a bit yeah
he just needs to chill out he's a little
guidance that's it
like a young kobe he just needs a little
phil like hey hey hey let's guide you a
little bit 100
phil jackson i got you mark earlier on
the pot we talked about one with two
vaginas all right guys we're gonna take
a break from this exclusive patreon
episode clip you get the whole episode
of patreon.com flagrant2 but i gotta
tell you all about the best thing in the
smoking business and that is freeze pipe
okay we all know that smoke is gonna
hurt your lungs hurt your throat it's
just gonna hurt you and how can we
reduce that hurt matter of fact make it
smooth and soothing you can use a freeze
pipe okay freeze piper the makers are
the smoothest hitting pipes and bongs
around today's episode is brought to you
by freeze pipe okay each freeze pipe
product uses freezable glycerin chambers
that cool smoke by hundreds of degrees
pop one of these glycerin chambers in
the freezer for an hour and as smoke
passes through the icy chamber it
instantly is chilled for a bigger colder
and smoother hit say goodbye to throat
and chest burn freeze pipe offers a
luxury smoking experience at every day
great prices so you have to do it this
is no-brainer this is the one that we
live by asthma like me a little baby
bird chest
come on now gotta make it good make it
go down smooth listen if you uh have
grown tired of burning throats or
coughing too much when you light up
visit
thefreezepipe.com and use the code
flagrant for 15 off remember that's the
freeze pipe.com use the promo code
flagrant for 15 off and say goodbye to
harsh cannabis poke now let's get back
to this exclusive patreon clip there's a
girl that has two [ __ ] apparently
last episode you were talking about uh
shauna ray who's a girl who's a a dwarf
yes and and and she's not a dwarf marker
she's a child and an adult she's not a
dork but she's an adult
you guys are crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
obviously i'll take it i'll take it that
was actually good that was i got a
[Music]
when you were talking about shauna ray
some people thought maybe you went too
far maybe you crossed the line wow
you said that we should feed her to
molesters i said she should offer it
yeah i think you said you should we
should feed her that legally
and she should be fed
to molesters yeah is what you said use
the correct tense yeah so some people
thought maybe that's too far so i think
when we bring up this story you should
just you know
try not to take it too far when we talk
about this one with two vaginas okay the
girl has two [ __ ] one she uses for
porn i believe
oh is this so here she is okay oh wait a
minute she's pregnant
she's not pregnant her name is evelyn
uncovered all right oh is one of the
[ __ ] her unborn kid no no yeah come
on
weird
i'm talking about these are two [ __ ]
though all right so it's it's a little
bit misleading okay so she put this out
she's been an escort for like eight
years and now she's got only fans with
her husband okay husband
yeah and she goes for it like she's
she's about that life all right okay all
right she doesn't really really have two
vaginas okay
she's got i guess it depends what what
is the definition of a vagina it's the
inside part oh dude that's
the inside i have no idea she got one
vulva okay with a fork in the road
and it can go either way and then she
got a uterus on both sides
hold on yeah i don't know what a vlog
why did you bring that one up
i've only seen one of them over in my
life
no that's the lips yes also that's the
labia majora and leonardo menorah yeah
monica o'hannica
yeah exactly and that's the outside part
okay so all the lips is a vulva yeah
so if you're ever going down you don't
say i'm looking at your vagina you say
i'm looking at your volvo depends you
might be looking inside too but then you
have to be specific
no you don't what you're talking about
no you don't know
okay so
you're telling me that she has two
vulvas no one vulva okay what's the
vulva again it's the whole whole thing i
don't know what the vault
weirdo he said he was gonna buy it now
you couldn't get it why can't you get it
i think we should do this right now
i i mean if she has two [ __ ] this
should be the number one only fans and
which one does the baby come out of so
she put it in the right
and the right he's stumped right
come on doc in the right how many holes
that's what i'm confused about
technically two
once you go in the one hole
there's two so it's okay it's like an
apartment two-bedroom apartment
two-bedroom apartment apartment exactly
so if there was a double guys just for
everybody in here a two-bedroom
apartment
it's like what you guys live in but like
with more space here's a diagram that
she wrote during her ama on reddit okay
good so that's the vulva right there
that's a vulva that's a vagina that's a
vagina ovary ovary uterus uterus all
right oh so that's fat
that's a wild dog so she could have
twins from two different dudes she could
have four kids yeah because you can have
two eats i mean yummy
that's some litter i don't believe that
that's she could have triple penetration
i don't believe that that's true that's
one hustle dog yeah
no but that drawing was one hole so she
claims that she can put a dildo in one
and then a penis in the other yeah
technically i mean she could do that we
can't go inside there's no way for us to
see like she just throw two dicks in her
and then she's getting double-dipped but
there's no way to see that one is going
through one canal the other is going
through though i need to see the canals
dude
i need to see it mark do you stop ow
i've never been more curious in my
entire life okay i need to see it dude
all right and you can't get it up i'm
gonna get these for you all right
i get it for her i bet
i mean this is just fascinating i think
she got that say what what kind of
cameras you think she got [ __ ]
internal cameras
yes just an endoscope yeah
it's a colonoscopy you've never seen a
colonoscopy anybody's pay for only fans
you can't see the two [ __ ]
that's a good ass point that's what i'm
saying i'm saying there's one hole she's
it's just marketing yeah it's just
marketing she's lying yeah
like that was a back of the napkin
science yeah
it's not real doctor [ __ ] no yeah you're
about to do that yeah
cause you literally do that
dude i don't think that this girl has
two [ __ ] no she said that she was
medically diagnosed she has pictures on
her only fans medically diagnosed with
what but like two [ __ ] syndromes do
sonograms what can't you do with
sonograms of a [ __ ] yeah but where's
the value add you know what i'm saying
like yeah what is the value
bro imagine having two [ __ ] inside
one it's useless that's a waste one hole
that's a weight you just have yeah you
have one hole that has extra rooms it
will be a little fun is it you can hit
like left right with it
nah but you're not going in different
avenues when you're doing it though
bro that was crazy looking at her butt
ass naked but pregnant i don't like that
i don't y'all i don't like it that's my
limit with porn i feel bad for this kid
or whatever her name is oh and the
shania girl i don't know that also i
don't like it yeah but the pregnant porn
i'm good on all that
yeah no that's up there with feet now
feet is fire guys you know what i i talk
about this maybe twice a week yeah once
a week about your fear of heights and
twice a week about your weird thing with
feet his is more specific than mine i
think i love michael black
watch his foot porn
no i don't know if you do that i don't
do that i don't watch porn
but uh if i did they have to have good
feet really yeah
that's as odd as that little diagram i
just saw what like you might as well
just draw a strong dog you don't like a
good foot yeah that's all i care about
there's so much more to like are you
with me on this
absolutely what you mean bro son feet i
don't give a [ __ ] don't count your toes
i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you care about
your own feet
that's fine yeah cause i wanna have some
nice looking feet okay so why would you
wanna have a girl
yeah dude i can't believe you don't care
about feet at all
are you the foundation of the body
though but maybe i've never had a really
bad foot right well okay my question is
what is a bad enough foot there bunion
there yeah i mean oh my god disgusting
bunion so bunions
okay i have it i don't need a girl to
have what i have right yeah that's what
i'm saying i've never been with a girl
like feet like i bet you have if you're
not paying attention no no yes yes you
have so is it that [ __ ] would be
scratching me like
is it trauma like if you have i didn't
talk about it because i thought i was a
freak and now i realize i'm right dawg
as him blau more dudes i was like oh i'm
not alone yeah we all love feet you're
supposed to love feet yeah there's no
trouble you didn't start with like
some hobbit feet like you woke up with
one of those in your mouth and you're
like no no i've just always there's two
things i've always really cared about
feet and uh no hair i don't like body
hair on women okay i like being girls so
i had to do away with that first one a
long time ago yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you make sacrifices to stay true
you know what i mean but initially you
were like that hair [ __ ] is wild
yeah whatever bro i didn't even think
about it i couldn't even let it enter my
mind really i'm too indian dog i'ma hate
hair yeah i guess yeah if you've seen
the indian girls also don't have great
feet oh that's a big thing when i met my
wife i was like i got to try to make
this work she had great feet yep
i don't see it yeah i've never looked
like i could have been with chicks that
didn't have feet and i couldn't have
told you you got a girl yeah what you
don't know what her feet look like
i mean i'm with him like there's so much
more to me i'm sure they're great
because why would they be bad
right why would the rest of her be
gorgeous and then she's just walking
around with like a he'd be shocked the
lord works in mysterious ways
what up people you just watch a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you